des milliers d'infirmières à nouveau
dans les rues de paris aujourd'hui un an
presque jour pour jour après la
manifestation qui avait regroupé cent
mille infirmières l'année dernière eh
bien on les a donc retrouvé aujourd'hui
dans la rue avec les mêmes slogans avec
les mêmes demandes
philippe de ses skis pour ces
infirmières et infirmiers le
gouvernement n'a pas tenu ses promesses
insatisfait sur les rattrapages
salariaux ils réclament de 1000 francs
d'augmentation le 13e mois et lui nul
francs minimum al embauche aujourd'hui
leur coordination entend surtout mettre
l'accent sur les mauvaises conditions de
travail de formation et sur la situation
de sous-effectif aussi la coordination
estime-t-elle nécessaire la création de
trente mille postes supplémentaires
création qui à tout point de vue n'est
pas évident on voit dans quelques ondées
travaillait de sous-effectif lot de
matériels sont pas remplacés par ceux de
plonger sous payés et que ça dégoûte
beaucoup de gens dit au départ était
encouragé cette progression nous avons
eu quelques poussières d'augmentation de
salaire sur lequel on a polarisé
l'attention du public mais en fait on
est très loin d'avoir obtenu ce qu'on
demandait notamment en matière
d'effectifs c'est à dire en matière de
conditions de travail qui sont plus
désastreuses cette année que l'an
dernier et week-end à l'hôpital les
fêtes à l'hôpital et nuit à l'hôpital
ça demande quand même de pouvoir le
faire dans de bonnes conditions et de
pouvoir être prêt à répondre à
l'angoissé un malade sans être obligé de
se sauver au milieu d'une phrase pour
aller répondre à une urgence médicale ou
chirurgicale
à midi la coordination été reçue au
ministère de la santé par le directeur
des hôpitaux réunion jugée de se vendent
par la délégation aussi le cortège at il
pris le chemin de l'hôtel matignon
il a trouvé porte close le cabinet
michel rocard rien jugé la délégation
trop nombreuses
elle était composée de 15 personnes au
lieu de 5 souhaité par les services du
premier ministre mais l'essentiel pour
la coordination c'est que le mouvement
de protestation soit relancée